vulnerable sounds weak right but
vulnerability simply is the expression
of of Doubt or uncertainty sometimes you
know saying I don't know is vulnerable
right
um saying this is going to be difficult
is vulnerable I think a lot of leaders
pretend they have all the answers or
pretend that they have no no uncertainty
and of course that's nonsense because we
all have uncertainty we all have doubt
um
um now you can't come to work and you
know go oh my God the whole thing's
gonna cry you know that's just a equally
unrealistic
um but uh you know when when you have a
company that allows for people to feel
vulnerable that means someone can raise
their hand and say
um I made a mistake or I need help or I
don't understand or I'm having trouble
at home and it's affecting my work or
I'm scared
um without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather they say it with
confidence that someone will rush to
support them and the way that you
encourage that kind of culture is that
the leaders have to set the example and
so during covid you know when I was
having when I was struggling as we all
went through a period of really of
mental struggle I said to my team I'm
off my game I'm really I'm struggling
you know it's getting to me and I just
need your help and your patience to to
that I may be pretty slow to respond and
not of it very effective for now you
know and I said that and that allowed
other people to speak up so that we
could be there for them but if I if I
pretended that everything was fine and
everything was good the whole time then
everybody's going to pretend
everything's fine and everything's good
and then how can we be there to support
each other until they crash so
um I think vulnerability is is is just
being a little more open and the irony
is is it takes tremendous courage and
strength to express vulnerability it's
actually strong to be vulnerable it
actually is very weak to pretend that
everything's fine yeah